- Are you a new parent?
Are you wondering when life
is gonna get back to normal?
Well, we've got some great
self-care tips for you.
(upbeat music)
- Checked out of the
hospital this morning.
We just got back.
You wanna come visit with all the kids?
That sounds great.
Fantastic, we'll see you soon.
- Mama, you spent 48 hours in labor.
They can wait 48 hours to meet that baby
if you want them to.
Let's see how this should've gone down.
- Oh, you wanna come over.
Um, we're actually not gonna
take visitors until next week.
Okay, man, thanks.
Appreciate it; alright,
we'll see you soon.
(upbeat music)
- You guys need any
help or anything or...?
- No, I don't think so.
- Yeah, we're good.
- Yeah, we're doing it.
- New parents should always
accept help when offered.
I recommend keeping a list on your fridge
of things that friends and family can do
when they come over and give
you that empty offer to help.
Let's see how that should
play out in real life.
- Actually, yes.
We're out of milk and diapers.
Can you go to the store
and get some please?
- And the dishwasher is full,
if you can empty it out.
Oh, the baby's new clothes
are just sprawled out
all over the living room.
What else; I don't wanna forget anything.
- Diaper pail.
(upbeat music)
- Hey.
- There is nothing more important
than making friends with other parents.
No matter how cool your
regular friends are,
they live on a different
planet from you now.
So, let's see what Shawn should've done.
- Hey, how's it going?
- Oh my God, man.
Am I ever gonna sleep again?
- Depends, how old is she?
- She's two months.
- Well, with my first,
she started sleeping
about four to six months,
so you gotta a little time
before the sleep starts,
but hang in there.
(upbeat music)
(yawning)
- You and your partner
made this baby together.
Try to remember each other's names.
Can we see that again?
(yawning)
- I love you.
- Te quiero.
- Muchisimo.
(upbeat music)
- You're not truly a parent
until some well-intentioned stranger
tells you to sleep when the baby sleeps.
And while that can be great advice,
it's just not always doable.
Here are some other options.
You could do something you miss,
like take a shower, binge watch a show,
spend some actual time with your spouse.
(upbeat music)
(baby crying)
- Can you take her?
I can't handle it.
- I can't take her right now.
There's a headache.
- I'm trying to get her to stop shrieking.
Stop please.
- It is hard enough
those first couple months
if you guys are battling each
other every step of the way.
Try to remember that you
made this thing together
and you're a team.
Let's see how dad could've done better.
- Oh my God, I can't, she's
been crying for over an hour.
- Okay, okay, let's tag team this.
You go outside; take ten,
and I'll get her fed.
(upbeat music)
But you come back.
You come back; ten minutes.